TUCKER CARLSON IS UP NEXT.
ONE NIGHT GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE HAVE A VERY LONG OPEN AND
SPENT ALMOST HALF OF LAST
NIGHT’S SHOW TELLING YOU ABOUT
THE RISE OF LEFT-WING MOBS IN
THIS COUNTRY, AND THE THREAT
THEY POSE TO ALL OF US.
WE TOLD YOU THAT NO MATTER WHAT
THEY ARE CLAIMING ON TELEVISION
OR HOW LOUDLY WE ARE CLAIMING
IT, THEIR MAIN GOAL IS POWER.
THEY WILL SILENCE YOU, HURT YOU,
THOUGH BURN YOUR COUNTRY DOWN,
AND THEY ARE DOING ALL OF THAT
NOW.
SO THE QUESTION IS, HOW SHOULD
YOU RESPOND TO THIS AND THE
ANSWER IS WITH COURAGE.
HERE IN AMERICAN COMING TO LIVE
IN A FREE COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE NOTHING TO BE ASHAMED
OF.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO APOLOGIZE FOR
CRIMES HE DID NOT COMMIT.
YOU HAVE THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO
SAY EXACTLY WHAT YOU BELIEVE IS
TRUE.
THAT IS YOUR BIRTHRIGHT.
NOW IS THE TIME TO AFFIRM THAT
RIGHT OUT LOUD.
IF ENOUGH DECENT PEOPLE RISE
FROM THEIR KNEES AND STAND DOWN
THE MOB, THE MOB EVAPORATES.
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT WARRIORS,
THEY ARE VAMPIRES.
THEY MELT IN THE LIGHT.
WHEN WE SHOW THEM WE ARE NOT
AFRAID, THEY GO AWAY.
THAT’S WHAT WE TOLD YOU LAST
NIGHT.
MINUTES AFTER WE SAID THAT, THE
MOB CAME FOR US, IRONY OF
IRONIES.
THIS BEEN THE LAST 24 HOURS
TRYING TO FORCE THIS SHOW OFF
THE AIR FOR GOOD.
THEY WON’T SUCCEED IN THAT,
THANKFULLY, THEY ARE NOT
INTIMIDATED AND WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THAT, BUT THE WHOLE THING
DIDN’T GET US THINKING THAT
WHICH WE SHOULD BE MORE SPECIFIC
ABOUT WHO THIS MOB IS AND WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
WHO ARE THE PEOPLE TRYING TO
TAKE OVER YOUR COUNTRY, CANCEL
YOUR RIGHTS, ELIMINATE OUR
CENTURIES LONG TRADITION OF
TOLERANCE AND FREE EXPRESSION.
THE TRUTH IS, WE OFTEN DON’T
KNOW THEIR NAMES.
MOSTLY FACELESS POLITICAL
AGITATORS WHO EXIST PRIMARILY
ONLINE.
THEY ARE TROLLS WHO THRIVE ON
CRUELTY AND YET THEY HAVE
IMMENSE POWER OVER ALL OF US.
WEAK LEADERS NOW REFLEXIVELY BOW
TO THEIR DEMANDS NO MATTER WHAT
THOSE DEMANDS ARE.
WHY IS THAT?
WHAT HAS CHANGED?
THAT’S MUCH LONGER CONVERSATION
AND WE PROBABLY OUGHT TO DO AN
ENTIRE SHOW ON THAT TOPIC AND IF
THE NEWS EVER CALMS DOWN LONG
ENOUGH TO THINK IN DIFFERENT
TERMS, WE WILL DO THAT.
BUT FOR NOW, IT’S ENOUGH TO SAY
THE COUNTRY’S DEFENSES BEEN
BADLY WEAKENED BY DECADES OF
RELENTLESS PROPAGANDA ALL
DESIGNED TO MAKE US FEEL WE HAVE
NO RIGHT TO STAND UP FOR
OURSELVES AND OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE TOO SINFUL TO RESIST AND
WE DESERVE WHATEVER WE GET.
SHUT UP AND TAKE IT, AMERICA.
WE CAN SPEND DAYS SHOWING YOU
EXAMPLES OF THIS, BUT HERE’S
JUST THE VERY LATEST FROM CNN
OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> BRINGING THE SIGN OF THE
PROTEST OF THE CENTER LATER.
>> THEY LOOK UPSET.
ARE THE PROTESTERS SAD?
>> THEY ARE SAD AND UPSET.
AND THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO BE,
ELMO.
PEOPLE ARE UPSET BECAUSE RACISM
IS A HUGE PROBLEM IN OUR
COUNTRY.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, PEOPLE OF
COLOR, ESPECIALLY IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY, ARE BEING TREATED
UNFAIRLY BECAUSE OF HOW THEY
LOOK.
>> Tucker: A CHILDREN’S SHOW.
GOT THAT, BOBBY?
AMERICA IS A VERY BAD PLACE AND
IT’S YOUR FAULT SO NO MATTER
WHAT HAPPENS, NO MATTER WHAT
THEY DO TO YOU WHEN YOU GROW UP,
YOU HAVE NO RIGHT TO COMPLAIN.
THAT’S THE MESSAGE AND IT STARTS
VERY YOUNG.
WHERE DOES IT END UP?
WE ARE FINDING OUT.
HERE’S WHERE IT ENDS UP.
A SERBIAN SOCCER PLAYER WHO
UNTIL THE OTHER DAY PLAYED
PROFESSIONALLY FOR THE GALAXY IN
LOS ANGELES.
LAST WEEK, HIS WIFE POSTED
CRITICISM OF THE LOOTERS SHE WAS
WATCHING BACK MINNEAPOLIS.
ROW IN SERBIAN, WHICH SHE
SPEAKS, AND YET SOMEONE NOTICED
THEM ANYWAY AND ATTACKED HER
PROVIDING THEM.
SHE DELETED THE POST VERY
QUICKLY, BUT IT WAS TOO LATE.
WE SHOULD BE CLEAR THAT HER
HUSBAND MAY NOT EVEN HAVE KNOWN
THAT SHE WROTE THE POST.
WIFE IS IN CHICAGO WHEN SHE
WROTE THEM, BUT IT DIDN’T
MATTER.
PROTESTERS DUTIFULLY ARRIVED AT
THE STADIUM TO CALL FOR HIS
FIRING.
SO THE MANAGEMENT OF THE L.A.
GALAXY FORCED HIM TO APOLOGIZE
FOR HIS WIFE AND THEN TO
DENOUNCE HER.
DENOUNCE HIS OWN WIFE.
THEN THEY MADE HIM ENDORSE BLACK
LIVES MATTER, WHICH HE DID AND
THEN FIRED HIM ANYWAY AND THEN
THEY ATTACKED HIM ON HIS WAY
OUT.
FOR SOMETHING HE DIDN’T EVEN DO
AND MAY NOT EVEN HAVE KNOWN
ABOUT THAT WAS WRITTEN IN A
LANGUAGE ALMOST NOBODY IN
AMERICA UNDERSTANDS.
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENED.
CHRIS KLEIN SEEMED PLEASED BY
THE WHOLE TEAM AND SAID "IN THE
END, WE HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT THE
CLIP STANDS FOR AND WHO WE ARE."
WHO WE ARE.
IT’S A GOOD QUESTION, ACTUALLY.
WHO ARE WE?
AT THIS POINT, WE ARE BECOMING A
NORTH KOREA.
WE NOW BELIEVE IN BLOOD GUILT,
WE PUNISH PEOPLE FOR THE SINS OF
THEIR RELATIVES.
WE DON’T ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO
HAVE PRIVATE THOUGHTS.
WE HEARD ANYONE WHO DISAGREES
WITH ORTHODOXY.
WE DEMAND THAT THE INNOCENT
BEAGLE TO DO THINGS WE KNOW THEY
DIDN’T DO AND THEN READ THEIR
CONFESSIONS IN PUBLIC AND THEN
WE BRAG ABOUT DOING ALL OF THIS.
OBVIOUSLY, SOMETHING TERRIFYING
HAS DESCENDED ON AMERICA AND
IT’S EASY TO STAND BACK AND SEE
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
TERRIBLE IDEAS SUDDENLY HAVE
FREE REIGN.
WHY?
BECAUSE NO ONE PUSHES BACK.
THEY ARE MET WITH SUPINE
WEAKNESS.
YOU’VE SEEN IT HAPPEN 1,000
TIMES.
SOME PROFESSIONAL ACTIVIST SAID
SOMETHING CRAZY BECAUSE IT’S
WHAT THEY DO, DEFUND THE POLICE.
WHAT HAS CHANGED AND WHAT IS
BRANDING WAS THAT NO ONE IN
CHARGE HAS THE STONES TO
DISAGREE, SO THE RHETORIC GETS
EVEN CRAZIER AND MORE
DESTRUCTIVE.
KILL THE POLICE?
OKAY, WHAT NEXT?
NOW INVESTIGATING A PROFESSOR
FOR THE CRIME OF READING
MARTIN LUTHER KING THIS LETTER
FROM BIRMINGHAM JAIL OUT LOUD.
MEANWHILE, ALSO AT UCLA, ANOTHER
PROFESSOR IS UNDER POLICE
PROTECTION TONIGHT.
WHAT DID GORDON KLEIN DO WRONG?
WHEN MINORITY STUDENTS ASKED TO
BE EXEMPTED FROM FINAL EXAMS
AFTER GEORGE FLOYD DIED, HE
REFUSED AND SAID EVERYONE OF ALL
COLORS HAS TO TAKE THE EXAM.
UCLA IMMEDIATELY SUSPENDED HIM.
DENNIS THREATENED TO KILL HIM.
NOW HE HAS POLICE CARS OUTSIDE
OF HIS HOUSE.
ALL OF THIS IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW IN AMERICA.
THE QUESTION IS, IS ANYONE
DEFENDING THESE GUYS?
DEFENDING THE RIGHT TO GIVE
EXAMS OR TO READ
MARTIN LUTHER KING OUT LOUD?
PROBABLY NOT.
NO ONE IS DEFENDING ANYONE
ANYMORE.
IS EVERY MAN FOR HIMSELF.
MEANWHILE, THE WORST IDEA, THE
ONES I COULD HARM ALL OF US ARE
GROWING IN POWER.
LAST WEEK, THE COSMETICS COMPANY
L’OREAL ANNOUNCED IT WAS HIRING
A BLACK TRANSGENDER MODEL.
WILL SIT ON THE NEWLY FORMED
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION ADVISORY
BOARD.
SHE HAD WORKED AT L’OREAL BEFORE
IF YOU FOLLOW FASHION, YOU KNOW
THAT, BUT GOT FIRED FOR WRITING
THIS SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED TO
WHITE PEOPLE.
GOING TO QUOTE FROM IT.
"YOUR EXISTENCE AND PRIVILEGE AS
A RACE IS BUILT ON THE DEATH OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
RACISM ISN’T LEARNED.
IS UNCONSCIOUSLY PASSED DOWN
THROUGH PRIVILEGE.
ONCE THEY REALIZE IT IS THE MOST
VIOLENT AND OPPRESSIVE FORCE OF
NATURE ON EARTH, THEN WE CAN
TALK.
NOW, SHE GOT CANNED FOR WRITING
THAT.
ANNOUNCED THAT CRACKPOT RACIAL
THEORIES WERE CONTRARY TO
DIVERSITY AND TOLERANCE TOWARD
ALL PEOPLE IRRESPECTIVE OF THEIR
RACE AND THAT OF COURSE IS TRUE
WHERE IT WAS, NOT TRUE ANYMORE.
L’OREAL HAS APOLOGIZED FOR EVER
SUPPORTING TOLERANCE AND
DIVERSITY AND HAS DOWN REHIRED
HER.
THE IDEA THAT RACISM CAN BE
INHERITED AND PASSED DOWN IS NOT
CONSISTENT WITH L’OREAL’S BLACK
LIVES MATTER INSPIRED HR
POLICIES.
SOME EMPLOYEES THERE MUST BE
WORRIED.
WE SHOULD ALL BE WORRIED.
THIS IS TERRIFYING.
WE SHOULD FIGHT AGAINST SWEEPING
RACIAL ATTACKS LIKE THIS WITH
EVERYTHING WE HAVE NOT BECAUSE
WE ARE SYMPATHETIC TO THE
SPECIFIC GROUP THEY ARE GOING
AFTER, BUT BECAUSE IT IS WRONG,
ALWAYS, NO MATTER WHAT, NO
MATTER WHO THE TARGET IS.
NO CHILD IS BORN EVIL.
SIN CANNOT BE INHERITED.
THAT’S INSANE.
CERTAIN RACIAL GROUPS ARE NOT
MORALLY SUPERIOR TO OTHER RACIAL
GROUPS, AND WE SHOULD NEVER
CONDEMN ANY ETHNICITY AS "THE
MOST VIOLENT AND OPPRESSIVE
FORCE OF NATURE ON EARTH."
THAT IS NOT THE TALK.
IS.
TODAY, THE LEFT HAS SINGLED OUT
ONE ETHNIC GROUP TO PUNISH BUT
TOMORROW IT WILL BE ANOTHER.
BIGOTS NEVER STOP WITH JUST ONE,
AND IT WILL BE EVERY BIT AS
WRONG WHEN THEY DO THAT TO OTHER
PEOPLE AS IT IS WRONG NOW
BECAUSE IT IS ALWAYS WRONG.
WE HAVE AN ENTIRE MONUMENT ON
THE NATIONAL MALL IN WASHINGTON
DEDICATED TO THE IDEA THAT IN
AMERICA, CITIZENS ARE JUDGED BY
THE CONTENT OF THEIR CHARACTER
AND NOT BY THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN.
WE DON’T ALWAYS LIVE UP TO THAT
IDEA, OBVIOUSLY, BUT IT’S GOT TO
BE THE IDEAL.
WE GIVE UP ON THAT, IF WE STOP
TRYING TO TREAT PEOPLE EQUALLY
UNDER THE LAW, THEN WE’RE DONE.
AT THAT POINT, THIS COUNTRY IS
SIMPLY A COLLECTION OF ANGRY
TRIBES AND VIOLENCE IS
INEVITABLE.
THAT’S WHERE WE ARE HEADING
TONIGHT HAVE VERY, VERY HIGH
SPEEDS.
DEMOCRATS ARE THRILLED BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE THEY CAN WIN THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION BY INCITING
TRIBALISM AND MAYBE THEY CAN,
BUT WHAT THEN?
HOW DO YOU PUT THE COUNTRY BACK
TOGETHER?
REPUBLICANS HAVE A MORAL DUTY TO
DEFEND US FROM THIS, TO STAND UP
NOW, RIGHT NOW, WHEN IT COUNTS
FOR AMERICA’S HIGHEST AND MOST
IMPORTANT IDEALS.
THIS RIGHT NOW IS THE CRISIS
THAT WE ALL SENSED WAS COMING.
THIS IS WHY WE VOTED FOR THEM.
WHEN IT REALLY MATTERED, THEY
PROMISED, THEY WOULD FIGHT TO
KEEP THIS COUNTRY FROM FALLING
APART.
NOW THE CRISIS IS HERE, AND THEY
ARE NOT EVEN TRYING.
MITCH McCONNELL IS THE MOST
POWERFUL REPUBLICAN IN THE
CONGRESS.
HE RUNS THE SENATE.
SO WHAT DID MITCH McCONNELL,
THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER DO
TODAY AS AMERICAN SOCIETY BEGAN
TO UNRAVEL?
HE DID NOT DEFEND THE COUNTRY,
MUCH LESS DEFEND YOU, HE READ
TALKING POINTS THAT NANCY PELOSI
COULD HAVE WRITTEN AND THAT
BENEFITED ONLY HER.
MANY REPUBLICAN SENATORS DID
THAT TODAY.
THESE PEOPLE ARE COWARDS, AND
THEY ARE LIARS.
THEY POSE AS YOUR PROTECTORS,
THEY WOULD SELL YOU OUT FOR THE
PRICE OF LUNCH AND LAUGH AS YOU
WERE HAULED AWAY.
AT THE VERY LEAST, THEY COULD
POINT OUT THE ENDLESS LYING ALL
AROUND US.
THEY WERE SO MUCH OF IT.
HERE IS ONE EXAMPLE, THE MAYOR
OF ATLANTA JUST ANNOUNCED THE
CREATION OF WHAT SHE CALLED A
RECOVERY FUND DESIGNED TO HELP
BUSINESSES DESTROYED IN THE
PEACEFUL DEMONSTRATIONS IN
ATLANTA.
WAIT A SECOND, IF THE
DEMONSTRATIONS WERE SO PEACEFUL,
WHY THE RECOVERY FUND?
YOU THINK REPUBLICANS COULD AT
LEAST POINT THIS OUT.
IT’S KIND OF AMUSING IF NOTHING
ELSE, A RECOVERY FUND FOR A
PEACEFUL DEMONSTRATION?
BUT NO, YOU CAN’T CRITICIZE
KEISHA BOTTOMS ANYMORE.
RESPECT IS DUE.
AND SO THEY’LL PUSH BACK ON THE
LINE CONTINUES RELENTLESSLY IN A
TORRENT FROM EVERYONE IN CHARGE,
AND NO ONE STOPS IT.
NO ONE EVEN ACKNOWLEDGES.
AFTER A WHILE, NO CITIZEN, NO
ONE WATCHING BELIEVES ANYTHING.
THE FEW PEOPLE WHO REMEMBER WHAT
AMERICA USED TO BE LIKE START TO
THINK MAYBE THEY ARE GOING
CRAZY, BUT THEY’RE NOT GOING
CRAZY.
IS NOT YOU, IT’S THEM.
THE COUNTRY REALLY HAS CHANGED
AND VERY FAST.
LAST FRIDAY, A MAN IN ALABAMA
SENT A TEXT AT SEVERAL OF HIS
EMPLOYEES, PART OWNER OF A
RESTAURANT IN ALABAMA CALLED THE
PARKSIDE CAFE.
PROTESTS OVER THE DEATH OF
GEORGE FLOYD WERE APPARENTLY
HURTING HIS BUSINESS AND HE WAS
FRUSTRATED BY THAT SO IN HIS
TEXT, HE CRITICIZED THE
PROTESTERS THOUGH HE ALSO NOTED
THAT GEORGE FLOYD "DIDN’T
DESERVE TO DIE."
OKAY.
THEN IN ONE OF HIS EMPLOYEES
PROMPTLY POSTED HIS TEXT TO
SOCIAL MEDIA AND CALLED HIM
HATEFUL AND EVIL.
IMMEDIATELY, HIS RESTAURANT WAS
BESIEGED.
THEY SAW THIS AND DECIDED TO
HELP.
OMENS OPEN OPENED A GOFUNDME
PAGE TO HELP THE PARKSIDE CAFE,
COMPENSATE FOR LOST BUSINESS
PRAYED WITHIN HOURS, DONORS SENT
IN MORE THAN $200,000.
TURNS OUT AN AWFUL LOT OF
AMERICANS STILL BELIEVE HE
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO EXPRESS
YOUR OPINIONS IN PRIVATE TEXT
MESSAGES.
WE USED TO TAKE THAT FOR
GRANTED.
BUT THE TAXPAYERS WHO RUN
GOFUNDME.COM DON’T BELIEVE THAT
AND DON’T WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
OTHERS BELIEVE THAT.
YOU’RE GOING TO CONTROL A
SOCIETY, AND THEY WANT TO,
YOU’VE GOT TO TREAT EVERY
ORDINARY DISSIDENT LIKE A
DANGEROUS REVOLUTIONARY AND SHUT
THEM DOWN.
GOFUNDME IMMEDIATELY SHUT DOWN
CANDACE OWENS’ ACCOUNT.
IN A STATEMENT, GO FUND THE
ACCUSED CANDACE OWENS OF
"INFLAMMATORY STATEMENTS THAT
SPREAD HATE, DISCRIMINATION, AND
TOLERANCE, AND FALSEHOODS
AGAINST THE BLACK COMMUNITY."
GO FUND MAY DID NOT ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT CANDACE OWENS IS HERSELF
BLACK, BUT OF COURSE IT WOULDN’T
MATTER ANYWAY BECAUSE RACISM NO
LONGER HAS ANYTHING TO DO WITH
RACE.
IT’S A WAY TO CONTROL
DISOBEDIENCE.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO CHANGED
HOW OUR PROFESSIONAL CLASS
UNDERSTANDS THE TERM RACISM.
THE AUTHOR OF THE BARELY
LITERATE BUT DEEPLY INFLUENTIAL
BOOK WHITE FRAGILITY.
PROBABLY HURTS SOME SOCIOLOGY
PROFESSOR YAPPING ON CNS CNN USI
THAT TERM.
SHE ANNOUNCED THAT CLAIMING
YOU’RE NOT RACIST IS NO LONGER
GOOD ENOUGH.
IN FACT, IT IS EVIDENCE YOU’RE A
RACIST.
"I WOULD URGE WHITE PEOPLE TO
REMOVE THE PHRASE I’M NOT RACIST
FROM THEIR VOCABULARIES."
YOU GOT THAT NEW RULE?
THEY SPRING UP OUT OF NOWHERE
LIKE MUSHROOMS AFTER RAIN BUT
YOU’D BETTER TAKE HEED.
PEOPLE SAY THEY ARE NOT RACIST
ARE ESPECIALLY RACIST.
GOT THAT?
IT IS THE CHINESE FINGER TRAP OF
RACE GUILT.
THE HARDER YOU STRUGGLE AGAINST
THE ACCUSATION, THE LESS LIKELY
YOU ARE TO GET OUT OF IT AND THE
MORE LIKELY YOU ARE BEING
PUNISHED FOR IT.
SO STOP RESISTING, SIT BACK AND
TAKE IT.
YOU HAVE NO CHOICE.
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE TELLING
YOU.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE WE USED TO
RESPECT OUR FALLING FORWARD,
CAVING TO IT, KNEELING DOWN
BEFORE IT.
DON’T BE ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
FOR THE SAKE OF THE COUNTRY,
STAY STRONG, BE BRAVE, BE KIND,
BE COMPASSIONATE, BE EMPATHETIC,
BE LOVING TOWARD YOUR NEIGHBOR,
BUT TELL THE TRUTH.